[Music]
since that date new Oh No
submitted by pink shoes to an awesome
man sues his date for texting during a
movie
oh my are you serious what a piece of
[ __ ]
how can you text how can you [ __ ]
sense in a movie oh my god so angry on
what grounds can you actually I'm
surprised you beat her up what so it's
more like you ruined my movie experience
give me my money back it's a combination
of iodine 12.95 you didn't kick me
during the movies give me my money back
that's not what I paid give us I cut a
hole at the bottom of the popcorn budget
and you didn't reach down and took them
above so this is Brandon this was a Mark
Ruffalo is seven years old 47 years old
thirty seven and you're suing for $17
that's why you don't got a girlfriend
could be I pick 13th up 30 ducks have a
good day 1:30 fold up cost thirty ducks
enough damn I don't know if I can go to
Ikea I don't know any ducks yeah
thirty does about money you're pretty
closed he's suing for seventeen dollars
and 31 cents oh [ __ ] what a loser than
the lawyer come flower maybe he took
them to [ __ ] Judge Judy so what the
news outlets are saying is that he's
suing her and then in the report they're
saying that like he's making these
claims that he's going to do something
about it with her like what like he's
like demanding the money back from her
is like oh like do I have to take you to
court
oh my god is this for China banned [ __ ]
away from him for the book Why What no
girls never gonna want to date him after
this story for sure now oh my god that's
why he's 37 he is the cautionary tale
now and he's going after 17 bucks ha ha
I will go after 17 bucks if I was 17
book you're not I'm not a
$17 a lot you know it's not matinee
so Brandon who has his own
communications consultant company said
that he met he's the worst
to communicate by going out of business
he met this woman online and went with
her on their first date to the movie
it's already a bad choice I mean you go
somewhere you can't even have
conversation yeah I always go mini golf
Tommy
learn you make a laugh that's the way to
the key to decide the arms around the
waist yeah
hers around that swing teach me how to
swing you feel that golf okay so the way
he describes the situation was it was
kind of a first date from hell about 15
minutes after the movie began she
started texting on her phone oh I know
what she was texting and this guy's a
[ __ ] loser candy and call me and
Justin to say that there's an emergency
Thanks probably so I have I I have her
stories oh I have a little bit of her
story so you're welcome know if it's
true I don't know okay so Brennan was
saying that like as she was texting on
her phone he was saying that you know
this is one of my biggest pet peeve so
he was describing that his date had like
the phone on her and like was at least
texting at least 10 to 20 times within
the first 15 minutes of the movie and
they were actually that's annoying
they're actually seeing guardians of the
galaxy - you bet not ruined that movie
it's a good movie lady and then we'll
have a he after the Keeney stop texting
and she was like no and so then he said
like maybe you should just go outside to
text and so at that point she decided to
go outside and then she just left the
theater oh of course that's perfect so
his dream came true why is he trying to
sue her now I mean I don't know like if
I don't know the person I would have
been like and everything cool like is
there emergency or like what's going on
because you don't know if you know most
people aren't trying to text all [ __ ]
date through the movie unless they're
just dumb apparently uh they rode
together
oh no when she drove off in her own car
he was right lit oh good thing that
doesn't mean anything does it
damn a few days later he actually texted
her this whole Thursday as a mother oh
we got receipt so here is the text convo
Wow I would just take it on the rear
take it up a lot
man what the [ __ ] 1d guys are a little
I'll be the guy do you be the guy okay
you read the blue bubble all right
yo it's an instance a yo just is blanked
out the name your behavior Saturday was
not only rude but it cost me money I
want you to compensate me for the 17
dollar movie ticket and the four dollar
pizza will you do this or do I have to
pursue the money in a small claims court
ah file online from my laptop and I'm
willing to do so your behavior was
wildly out of line I'm happy to pursue
putting you on the books for it dude
this [ __ ] behaviors so key be all baby
oh yeah
I'll just go sorry and she says are you
serious
my best friend needed me right away and
you said my phone was driving you crazy
then I felt so uncomfortable I can't
believe you would take it as far as
going to court this is insane exactly
[ __ ] sack of [ __ ] that's why you
don't tell her this is bothering me you
go are you okay yeah this is like those
[ __ ] nerds that go on a date and then
they go into a debate with a girl about
Star Wars and get heated and [ __ ] and
they're like well [ __ ] you then
it's like you're just [ __ ] [ __ ]
blocking yourself dude god damn if
someone texted me that yeah I would you
block your number right away
yeah so bewildered small claims court
are you morning so like the rest of his
bubble is pretty much cut off but what
you can read is that he says yes I'm
absolutely serious you're out of line
and I'm not the sole petty ass [ __ ]
there's so many guys cock-block
themselves knowing what he won dollars a
lot of money go to class go to Twitter
now let's see what he says well he might
be - yeah she's like where you live
available
we make a full-time I got 1731 and
Twitter let's do 70 Wow she made that
joke in my minutes gosh thank you yeah I
definitely just turn that one late so
apparently the girl's best friend
actually got into a fight with her
boyfriend and so she was just trying to
help her friend out x4 is [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no no every normal person like if you
don't know this person the first thing
you say is are you is everything okay
you don't say hey that's that's that's
Bob it's driving me crazy right you're
not you haven't been together for two
years that's the kind of [ __ ] that you
say when you've been together for a
while on the other hand go to give him
some sort of slack no we didn't censor
huge it but just proper etiquette states
that you're going to be a movie you're
going to be in the company of someone
else especially on a first date you're
going to be in a phone just to say hey
I'm so sorry this is an emergency I have
to handle this right now and that's it
that's all you really have to do she
should have said that for sure and he
should not be a Chris I should send him
ten bucks and then call it a day
yeah she should just send or just do a
rematch rematch gate open even when to
the extent to even contact his dates
little sister foot okay you've got to
talk super bitter there's no he doesn't
need sense I want to come and give him
back his money but I'd rip it all up
usually useful actually really wanted to
continue something with her absolutely
walking bitter yeah you know what you
cock-blocked yourself because you had
the opportunity to be like tough
guardians of the galaxy I got your back
girl I'll Drive you there or whatever
she drove you like it's cool let's go
let's handle this [ __ ] I'll be with you
man let's do it see that's why I get the
food man and he doesn't hey she said
that she was helping on a friend who was
having a fight with her boyfriend right
so she also was saying that she had her
phone on low and she wasn't bothering
anybody and it's not like she was
constantly texting and so when she was
confronted with his text message of like
hey you owe me this much she was just
like whoa it took me out on a date that
to reason and so she didn't feel the
need to pay him back she only to find
that she doesn't but this was acting
like his $3,000 she owned an event yeah
you don't need a pan back yeah it's just
the principle he just really wants to be
right he's super petty if it wouldn't
yeah I would either pay in exactly 1731
like male 30 one penny or all in pennies
I like that more than postage but I
might make a better fellow poster it
might make a better impact or I came
like twice as much and be like have a
nice life food oh oh I don't need your
money bid yeah money in a bank
$30 taking you know after looking at it
his Twitter and just scrolling through
if he's just soaking up all the
attention Oh like retweeting supposed to
like other new sources like write about
it Oh what it was oh no we're enabling
him like talking about it right now
he's probably watching this right now I
get it famous I heard it dick is really
small yeah I don't know I just don't
know anyone I want to date this guy
anymore
yeah yeah a little [ __ ] blocker a
self-induced [ __ ] blocker blows my mind
that there's so many guys like this in
the world and they don't understand why
they can't have a relationship I hope
there's not guys like this others there
are a lot of guys like this billions of
them actually a lot billion Oh Jane one
seventh of the world a guy asked me on a
date and I rejected and you should have
got angry at me
yeah he was like well why not and I was
like because I'm not interested and then
you're like like what you know you
should just give a guy a chance and I
was like I'm sorry but this is me
telling you I'm not interested I don't
know how to break it I wouldn't be mean
I wasn't be like no yeah it was just
like no it's okay right yeah it's okay
you don't you don't having me like
nobody got angers you for rejecting them
yeah no I don't think I reject misses
thank you for useful no I know I'm step
to me though oh you gotta be kidding you
don't like actually like you know no one
really you famous on
wait it sounds like really sad but like
no one really I'm pretty sure you get a
lot of dick pics in your DM I'm pretty
sure you're not accepting them and
saying nice like people I know I'm
friends with them all well that's
different cause it's friend zones right
like I'm not I'm not on any of the
dating after anything so I don't like
people at the grocery store hit on me
but I'm like cool thing they don't give
you a lame response when you turn them
down no well they're always like give a
boyfriend and I'm like yeah and I don't
and like oh that makes sense
so I mean I'm rejecting them without
being like I don't want they're just a
liar I see yeah how about them
cantaloupes though how do you ski how do
they pick up on a grocery store in the
gross that's like I've never done that
before that guy hit on like a celery you
like back it was so weird I was just
pumping gas and then someone's like hey
can I be number and I'm like oh my god I
was like oh no I'm married that was
awesome what you can't get out of it
anymore like it was awesome
and then he was like okay but it's like
just that random like that cold what
would be the best and most I guess
appropriate way for somebody to approach
it in that type of scenario because like
the guys probably just thinking to
themselves this is my one shot it's not
like I'm gonna follow this person nor do
I know where they are so I have to make
some sort of move what would be the best
most I think if they saw something like
that like hey this was my one shot like
I this is this is really weird I don't
know I feel something toward you for
some odd reason I thought the gas
station yeah hey you over there wipe in
his window like I am nervous I you may
not believe what I'm saying but I feel
some sort of connection I would like to
explore that if you don't mind like
maybe I can catch you like maybe I can
have your number if that's too weird
because you don't like you wanna mean
like the more raw and honest yeah the
person could be I can give homeless
people money when they approach them
like that because there's a homeless
people okay can I have some money and I
know I handle no [ __ ] up until I
yell I don't you know I'm just kind of
down on my luck and I just didn't catch
the bus to go home I feel badly when ask
you them right erupting your dinner
buddy you're connected but I'm like keep
alright cuz it's mutual respect when
it's like a conniving number you're like
definitely it's like August you just
want to [ __ ] now correct you're not
trying to make
any connection people might like use
that as a means to first possible you
can feel it too sometimes that's a
[ __ ] because y'all over here are
above the average person so today a
Queen's y'all need Kings so you need
somebody that you feel like oh my god
you're like different to watching you
know I put my own some time oh yeah my
mine because y'all got a date no basic
[ __ ] guarantees no BB I think if you
come at it with a joke that's good too
if the joke is funny but they have to be
attractive three super attractive and
charming like that means the only day
stand-up comedian no yeah sit down
have you ever been with a comedian yes
we're actually not what we seem like in
person true yeah to me is a doctor you
see on the outside is the opposite in
the inside [ __ ] so you're not funny on
the inside it's all kinds of glands all
Konza it's [ __ ] murder here and then
rainbows out here I don't think most
stand-up is about rainbows I think it's
usually dark mayor and then inside is
actually good no I like how you're going
with this because I like to see myself
as that hope you guys enjoyed that
episode if you guys have any juicy
little guts of details and you guys want
submit it well guess what you can cruise
on over to the description box below
click on the link submit the story and
hopefully we will pick it and talk about
it for more videos click right over here
[Music]